let's talk about one of the most powerful
vitamins for healthy skin well it's not vitamin e
or vitamin c these are very important but what's
even more important is vitamin b3 and that is
because if you are deficient in vitamin b3 you
could end up with a condition called pellegra
but there's also a subclinical version of a b3
deficiency which is not the full-blown disease but
a condition where you have dermatitis
dry brittle skin scaly skin red skin
even skin that is cracking is bleeding so vitamin
b3 is essential for keeping your skin very very
healthy at a very deep level it protects and
restores your dna so it actually goes very very
deep and vitamin b3 does a lot more than just
helping you with your skin helps cholesterol
it can decrease the risk of schizophrenia and
depression but in 1931 a chemist discovered
if you give a patient with pellegra vitamin b3
they become cured it gets rid of their pellegra
so that's when they connected the link between
pellegra being a vitamin b3 deficiency and they
found that people that had pellegra were consuming
way too much corn or flour refined flour or rice
or drinking too much alcohol so what they did to
solve this problem at that time was instead of
telling people to avoid corn flour and rice they
enriched the grains with synthetic version of
vitamin b3 and other vitamins now if you've been
watching my videos for a while you're probably on
healthy keto you're doing intermittent fasting
and you don't really have to worry about this
because you're not consuming corn flour rice
or well alcohol maybe you are a little bit but
hopefully not too much and you've probably noticed
that your skin is really great but if you're new
to my channel and you're still consuming these
foods you may need some b3 i'm going to recommend
you would take it in a niacinamide form this is
the one that doesn't give you that red flushing
sensation vitamin b3 can also help decrease the
risk of the brown spots on your skin decrease
risk of skin cancer it has anti-aging factors
for your skin it can also help you decrease acne
and this is probably why a lot of these skin
creams have this as one of the ingredient
now i found that you can get vitamin b3
in pretty much any food that you eat so
that's really not the problem the problem is
consuming certain things that are depleting
b3 so anyway i just wanted to make this connection
for you in case you might be deficient in b3 this
could be a simple solution thanks for watching
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and
you need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help you
this is just for the people in the us hopefully in
the future we'll be able to answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help